the CDC is warning about a shortage of
the newest shingles vaccine Shing Rick's
was recommended for people 50 and older
beginning last fall it is more effective
than the old vaccine at preventing the
painful shingles virus but the demand is
greater than expected and many patients
are having trouble getting the shot our
dr. David agus is here good morning when
you glad so why is it so difficult to
get the shot well demand is great and so
this is a it's a really potent excellent
vaccine I got it myself and this is a
vaccine where the old vaccine worked 30
40 percent of the time this is 97
percent of the time and remember over
1/3 of the population will get shingles
so this is something for everybody over
the age of 50 shingles is chickenpox we
all had as a child and that vaccine lies
dormant and as we get older and our
immune system goes down that can come
back up and it can have debilitating
consequences sometimes the rest of
people's lives so it's very important to
get this vaccine and vary the population
over the age of 50 so whether you have
any symptoms whatsoever you're saying be
proactive go get it before you have
Cynthia yes get this vaccine it is I
know it has something to do with
chickenpox what does it do so when you
get chickenpox as a child your immune
system takes over and it knocks it out
but it goes dormant inside your nerves
and as we get older or stress because
sometimes young look at it stress
suppresses the immune system and that
virus pops up again yeah and so what
this vaccine does is it makes our immune
system an extra-strong so that doesn't
happen and it really is critical that we
get it's a two part shot so one on day
zero and then the other shot month two
through six you know when I got it it's
such a potent vaccine that night I had a
little bit of fever and chills I felt it
I had tylenol and I felt better but it
is a very potent vaccine and it works
the problem is is that there's not
enough of it to go around right now so
call ahead to a pharmacy make sure they
have it you can get it at a pharmacy
your doctor's office insurance should
cover it because it's recommended by the
CDC but it really is critical to get it
and find a way find out when the next
shot batches coming and get on that list
and get the shot I was gonna ask you
because I've known friends that had
shingles as well and they described it
it's extremely pain
so for those who want to get the shot
now and did the vaccine isn't available
should they get the old vaccine no so
you know people who know even people who
have the old vaccine need to get the new
vaccine so they're there every week
they're releasing more of it so get on a
list figure out where it is it's not a
critical shortage but it's a shortage so
find that new vaccine whether it be a
doctor or pharmacy or somewhere okay we
are on time where you release your phone
number for people that you can house
call on our website
you know Gail and yeah will rein in that
person because Gail is a big baby stuff
that was the first doctor David agus
thank you so much